Speaker 1: So some of you might remember that
last week, I said to you jokingly, of course,
when the world is complicated, when I need
moral clarity and when I really need to know
what's taking place geopolitically, it's such
difficult times. I say to myself, What is
Tulsi Gabbard opinion now? That was a joke,
but the full joke is actually, I think, what
would Tulsi Gabbard say? But what would televangelist
Pat Robertson also say? And now we know Pat
Robertson, who is now 91 years old, of 700
club fame. Christian televangelist, who has
previously said that so many things are demonic.
I'm going to try to go from memory here. Pat
Robertson has previously said, Let me think
now yoga, Harry Potter, Weegee boards sometimes
adopted children, sometimes second hand sweaters.
Man, what else? All of these different things
can be demonic and have demons attached to
them. So Pat Robertson seemingly coming out
of retirement to explain why Russia has invaded
Ukraine, and I have to tell you, I'm actually
actually fascinated by it. I really find this
type of stuff fascinating because he's completely
created an imaginary world that he, I guess
believes exists with end times and messages
from God and stuff about the Pharisees. I
don't even know I'm going to play it for you,
and I I wish I had. I mean, it's almost like
a child like imagination that the guy has.
Check this out. It is wild.
Speaker 5: Here we go. Is out of his mind.
Yes, maybe so, but at the same time, he's
propelled by God. He went into the Ukraine.
Speaker 1: But by the way, Pat Robertson still
using the term, the Ukraine, which is just
a signal of, you know, how long he's been
commenting on these things, I guess,
Speaker 5: wasn't his goal. His goal was to
move against Israel ultimately, and he will
link up with Turkey with Azerbaijan. I mean,
it was across the Dardanelles and that little
bridge and they will come together. And then
you look down into North Sudan and you've
got a Muslim country down there and there
they all are. Persia, of course, is Iran,
and there is the land that is set up in a
zeal th8 right to see how Ukraine is key because
of the sea, the land bridge between Bulgaria,
Greece and Turkey. And all of that area is
going to be mobilized against Israel in the
latter days. And God says, I am going to deal
with it
Speaker 1: now, guys, I understand when Pat
Robertson says the latter days, he's talking
about a sort of apocalyptic rapture and times
when, when he says latter days, he means the
end as he believes to have been biblically
prophecy. Isn't this stuff just fascinating?
Speaker 5: So you can look at your map? You
can read the newspaper here and listen to
your news. But no of a fact that God is bringing
to pass what he prophesied years ago through
his sermon. Ezekiel.
Speaker 1: Now I always it's always tough
for me to understand Do these Christian extremist
types want the end times? Because, like with
some of them, from what I recall and I've
interviewed some of them as well, it's just
so hard to keep track of all of it. I think
some of them want the end times because they
believe that Jesus comes back then and again.
Correct me if I'm wrong. Everybody who's been
good gets eternal life with Jesus or something
like they consider the Rapture to be good
because the sinners are killed. But you want
to usher in the end times. I think even though,
like most everybody dies, which you and I
might be like, Well, that's bad, sir. But
I think I think people like Pat Robertson
want the end times,
Speaker 5: and you read it in the thirty nine
thirty eight classes of Ezekiel, one through
six is all there, and God is getting ready
to do something amazing. And that will be
fulfilled at what Putin is doing by moving
as he is to set up Ukraine as a staging ground
for one of the armies. And then across is,
is Erdogan a Turkey? And you've got between
them that little Dardanelles area and it's
going to happen. So I just say that is what's
coming up. Is Putin crazy? Is he mad? Well,
perhaps, but God says, I'm going to put hooks
in your jars or I'm going to draw you into
this barrel, whether you like it or not. And
he's being compelled after the move into the
Ukraine, he's being compelled to move again
to get a land bridge and then across the Dardanelles
with Turkey and watch what's going to happen.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, yeah, as many of you
will notice, Pat Robertson is not looking
great, but it still sounds like the same old
Pat Robertson with some of those same same
ideas so that that is really wild. I have
to tell you, there's some weird way in which
I envy people who are able to be so certain
about things for which we have no evidence
and just allow themselves to be completely
absorbed into that. And it sort of seems like
you don't have a care in the world in the
sense of it's sort of like what the conspiracy
theories. Everything is controlled. It's all
predetermined. It's all planned. It's just
like it's going to be what it is. There's
something about being able to fall for that
that I almost envy because it seems easier
than realizing the complexity and uncertainty
of the world that we that we live in and that,
hey, we actually have an impact here. It's
not just like, well, you know, Putin, it's
all ordained by God. Putin's going to do what
he's going to do, and that's really it. It's
been prophesied as as a practical matter.
Pat Robertson's predictions aren't very good.
And just as one example, here is one where
he said Trump's going to win. And much like
it was hard to tell whether that last clip
was an endorsement of Putin or a condemnation
of Putin. It's hard to tell whether this clip
is an endorsement of Trump, but he was sure
Trump was going to win, which he didn't. Of
course,
Speaker 5: there's going to be a war is Zaky
kill. Thirty eight is going to be the next
thing, by the
Speaker 1: way, is any talking about his equal?
Thirty eight in both clips
Speaker 5: on the line. Then a time of peace,
then leave it there, but nobody knows the
day or they to come back, he said. The angels
don't know if right, and only the father knows
it. So I'm not saying this is the second coming,
but I am saying there are things that people
have thought would be during a millennial
time or with the coming of Jesus. But it won't
happen in our lifetime. And the next thing
is the election was coming up in just a few
weeks. Right. At which time, according to
what I believe, the Lord told me, the president
is going to be reelected. And I'm saying by
all means, get out and vote. Vote for whoever
you want to vote for. Right? By all means,
let your voice be heard. But it's going to
lead to civil unrest of great proportions,
then a war against Israel and so forth and
so on. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So you know, the Israel the Lord
getting back to Israel didn't happen. Trump
didn't get reelected, but that is really something.
And he has been predicting end of the world
stuff for a really long time. In 1982, I wasn't
even alive yet. He predicted that the judgment
on the world was coming very, very soon. In
2006, he said the Pacific Northwest would
be devastated by a tsunami in 2007. He said
mass killings would be unleashed in America.
I believe at one point he predicted an asteroid,
and that didn't happen either. But OK, I mean
that it is what it is, and that's Pat Robertson's
perspective. And even with the Trump thing,
it's like, OK, so. Is is it good or bad if
the end times come, you can't really tell
from how he says it, he's like Trump's going
to win and then there's going to be unrest
and we're going to get closer to the end times.
But do you like that or do you not like that?
It's never totally clear with these guys.